now 6 25 on your friday morning we've
got some ramp closures where the 95
meets the northern 215 beltway come on
along let's go
centennial bowling
okay so we do have a couple of ramp
closures want to make sure you're aware
of now the first one actually started
last night supposed to wrap up at five
this evening
that's the ramp where you get off the
northbound 95 to go on to buffalo
ndot says that work involves patching up
a new bridge and putting in one of those
overhead signs
part of the centennial bowl project now
the other ramp closure is next
tuesday so before it gets lost in all
the election coverage here's the scoop
starting at eight
that morning you won't be able to get
onto the south 95 from northeastbound
durango to a one-day
repaving project supposed to finish at
four that'll give you time to get home
to watch eight news now coverage of the
election
if you've already voted good for you if
you have it i hope you do whichever way
works for you
of course don't forget the heads up
today's the last day for early voting
now all of this information is on
our website 8newsnow.com you click
traffic then driving you crazy
please buckle up drive carefully and put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com